sometimes I will forget the alphabet is
anybody else forgot in the alphabet all
right yeah I don't forget the letters
but I do forget the order that the
letters are supposed to go in so what I
did is I came up with a mnemonic device
to help remake me remember the order of
the letters of the alphabet this is
something that you can say to jar your
own memory if you ever forget okay
acronym based comedy doesn't ever feel
good honestly
I just keep lamenting my negative
opinion perhaps questioning reality
serves the universe very well xylophone
yak zebra
thank you thank you are you guys okay if
I try out some new jokes is that Alright
thank you now this is for TV hi mom hi
dad you know but so so I want to make
sure that I'm training myself to kind of
do these right normally I tell a joke
and get to laugh it doesn't get a laugh
I want to do that little quicker so I
thought how did I train my dog right so
what I'm gonna do here I'm gonna put on
his shock collar okay and I'm gonna give
the remote to one person in the audience
and thank you if you guys wouldn't mind
shocking me if you don't like a joke it
would do me a big favor thank you
somebody in the front row you raise your
hand too quick okay I'm not gonna go
okay you thank you wonderful okay
there's a big red button now this is a
real shock collar we've never met this
is not pre-planned so go ahead and press
the red button so we all know it's real
okay great
only press the button if you don't like
a joke okay because you are
electrocuting a man on television okay
here we go what do you guys think about
gluten-free bread for a boy's name
all right okay whoo no boy I think the
people in Los Angeles get a bad rap you
know I think we're way more giving than
we get credit for the other day on the
side of the road somebody left out some
candles
I know Yeah right some stuffed animals
just for anybody to pick up there was a
portrait of an old man you know all
right okay I'd love to thank the guy but
all it says is rip Dave you know what I
mean all right the other day Google
asked me to reset my password they sent
me they said I needed eight unique
characters so I entered an entire
Tennessee Williams play great okay
noted a little about me where I come
from a group in the science projects
that's cheap government housing another
fake volcanoes thank you thank you okay
[Applause]
you would not believe how surprised I
was when I found out that Roe vs. Wade
was not about ways to navigate water I
[Applause]
said you're trying to repeal what a
prime minister is a minister that can
only be divided by itself and one all
right use them in that ancient Roman
sitcom party of VIII no using the
ancient Romans sitcom III's company no
do you spent ancient Roman sitcom
friends and countrymen no D is an
ancient Roman action-adventure TV show
the Alpha Team nobody gives an ancient
Roman car movie I I fast I i furious no
I bet you guys like the modern stuff
like the ten files right
I'm gonna do some impressions for you
guys these are gonna go quick but feel
free to shock me between alright here we
go first impression this is my
impression of a suicidal germaphobe
thank you very much next impression this
is my impression of a matchstick ah
thank you guys so much
okay last impression this is my
impression of a man that does not know
that he has brain cancer god traffic is
the worst right
you